نصف العاملات في حياكه السجاد من طالبات
المدارس والجامعات اتقان نسوي ادى الى
زياده في الانتاج والتصدير رغم العقوبات
الدوليه على افغانستان وصعوبه التحويلات
الماليه
لدي في هذه الورشه اكثر من 100 امراه
معظمهن كنا طالبات لكن بعد قرار منع
التعليم لجانا الى هنا على الاقل يحصلن
على لقمه العيش فالاسره الافغانيه تعاني
ماليا
صناعه السجاد في افغانستان تنخرط فيها
عائلات باكملها فالمهنه تساهم في تحسين
اقتصاد البلاد مع الحفاظ على عراقه النمط
التقليدي في الحياكه ازدهرت صناعه السجاد
في افغانستان على حساب تعليم الفتيات
وعملهن في القطاع العام والخاص
وانخرط الفتيات في سوق عمل شاق ضمن ما
تسمح به معايير الحكومه الافغانيه الجديده
بعد حياكه السجاده يتم غسلها عده مرات ثم
تنشيفها على مراحل بعد ذلك يتم التهذيب
الزوائد وعموما تمر صناعه السجاد الافغاني
بثلاث عشره مرحله قبل ان تكون جاهزه للبيع
عامه الناس لا يعرفون جوده السجاده من
الوجه لذا الافضل ان يقلبها للتاكد من
جودتها وطريقه نسجها واتساقها بالاضافه
الى لين حياكتها
في محل بيع السجاد تعرض تشكيلات وتصاميم
متنوعه لم يعد السجاد الافغاني ينافس سجاد
ايران وتركيا فحسب بل صار ينافس سجاد دول
اسيا الوسطى ويراهن الافغان على الكلفه
المناسبه لصناعه السجاد عندهم اضافه الى
علاقته ناصر شديد الجزيره من مدينه مزار
شريف شماليه افغانستان